à ce que ce que nous on reproche
beaucoup française ses lettres
extrêmement choix parce que le belge est
pas du tout c'est comme une drogue dure
pour moi être français ce suv beaucoup
trop pour moi être français c'est être
très cultivé mais surtout pour briller
en société
[Musique]
jambon beurre gens m'ont le regard
elmander a tant marqué la présence pour
moi être français c'est croire qu'en
france il n'ya pas l'accent et encore
moins à paris évidemment les autres qui
ont un accent on va se poser en terrasse
et un serveur super aimable arrive
comment est-ce qu'on veut boire pour
qu'elles répondent tout naturellement
une 50/50 quoi centilitres mais de quoi
de bière mais quelle bière
moi je pense que la bière en terrasse en
france elle est excessivement cher
est-ce qu'on pourrait rectifier le tir
s'il vous plaît au revoir
pour moi c'est quoi les français le
français c'est des gens qui posent des
questions du genre c'est que les
français qu'elle te sais que cette
question on de jeu enfin de 60 millions
fait mal et ya de tout dans les
frontières si en france tu viens
il faut en 7 et 10 fois avec un très
mauvais accent en plus
les français qu'anglais la coupe du
monde pensait avoir gagné pour les 20
prochaines années
un petit cliché sur les français bah je
vois ap
j'ai carrément pas idée mais après la
belgique c'est le chant mais 1 600 mhz
et adjet à bruxelles